well since now you're the most famous
person on the YouTube channel I figured
I had to get you back on you loved
Andrew Tate would you give him a one out
of ten they probably gets an eight or
nine you're definitely a fan so Andrew
Tate recently just converted to Islam
we'll watch it with you so you can give
your thoughts and stuff I wanted to ask
you now because this is the Hot Topic
especially in the Muslim Community about
your conversion yeah so tell us the
story like what happened exactly well I
think a lot of people have been
following me for a while understand that
I've been very respectful of Islam for a
long time I was born in a Christian
country I was raised as a Christian and
I've always been very respectful of
Islam and it's become more and more
obvious to me and and more and more
pertinent that Islam is the last
religion on the planet when I talk about
Islam because I'm new to it yeah I I'm a
little bit careful right because I'm new
to it I'm certainly not scholar there's
so much I need to learn I know I'm on so
what do you even know about Islam did
you grow up with any Muslims around you
or like you were just totally not around
not at all completely ignorant although
through the years we've met people in
different religions but not a lot where
I was brought up we were mainly
Catholics and we were very ignorant to
other religions but I've learned a
little bit through the years and talking
with people and the more I find that
we're different religions or beliefs
we're the same we all want the same
thing like it's fundamentally the same
things we believe totally the same we
want to live a good life we want our
children to have good lives we teach our
children respect and morals as different
as we are that's how much the same we
are a Learning Journey I'm not here to
sit there and talk scripture I don't
know those things yet I'm here to learn
but we're here at your assistance thank
you brother thank you thank you but um
it's just for me it feels like the last
religion on Earth I feel like there's no
other religion people say to me why did
you convert I said I don't really feel
it as a conversion I it's almost like I
knew God was real and now I've become
religious and they say oh you're
religious before I was like religious
before how Christian what does Christian
mean like who's no all Christian you go
to Christian nations and everyone says
they're a Christian look how they live
their lives go into the average church
is anyone actually fearful of God
anybody what do you think about that
because I definitely agree with him as
to like Christians they don't even like
the idea of fearing God I'm a Catholic
but I follow it to the not to the T but
I do follow it by basic state in me they
like basic moral stuff yeah you know go
to church on Sunday which I don't do all
of the time I go occasionally but
inwardly I still believe and I followed
the Catholic church we all change your
different beliefs different I've had so
many friends through the years I'm old
and you know I've met a lot of people
and different religions and we all back
to the same thing we all want the same
thing I notice that people who change
religions they're the people that really
really work at the religion we all just
take our religion for granted but when
you have new people when you convert
into it yeah you hundred percent take it
more 100 because it's your choice you're
not just born born in do it right you're
not told like I was brought up a
Catholic always go to church and I was
told about the Catholic church and God
and the devil and all that and which is
fine I still believe in all of that but
I think if I convert to another religion
I am going to really read about that
religion and know about it and the new
people are the ones I think that keep
the religion going because the older
people just become lacks and take it for
granted so I think he's doing a good
thing as long as you believe in
something I don't care if it's the
picture on the wall believe in it it's
definitely really interesting like the
God-fearing stuff because when me and my
mom were watching the video she like she
hated the thought of like you know if
you if you do bad you get punished for
it and I kind of felt the same way at
first and then the more I thought about
it it's like well if you do good you get
rewarded so obviously if you're
willingly just constantly doing bad
stuff then doesn't it make sense to be
punished like shouldn't you have that
fear to do good so you don't do bad to
others I mean that kind of makes perfect
sense to me the more I think about it it
does and I think everybody should have a
little bit of fear in them I mean we
grew up we were afraid of all parents
yeah you know I always said I never
smoked as a kid and I still don't smoke
because I used to say if I went to China
and lit up a cigarette my mother would
be standing in back of me and I was
always fearful of that and I know
unfortunately today people don't bring
their children up with that little bit
of fear you should be a little bit of
fear of your teacher of your parents of
your elders it's just called respect
really
I agree oh the girls are out on Saturday
night drinking and they turn up to
church because their parents made them
but there's there's no substance to the
religion and also
Islam very closely reflects my personal
beliefs I through my personal life I've
learned that if you don't have standards
and you're not a strong person who's
prepared to defend his ideas you will be
crushed yes and we look at most
religions in the world today which are
not prepared to defend their ideas
what's happened to them they're just
getting crushed and now we have
Christianity as an idea which is
basically said well we can't set any
firm rules because everyone will just
quit so instead let's make it so easy to
be a Christian that nobody has to put
any effort in and then accept everybody
no matter what and hopefully we can keep
the church's doors open that's not
that's not God to me you know do you see
that as more of like a loving accepting
thing or as like he said just so you're
that accepting so you can just keep the
doors open and people will keep joining
because if people have to stick by the
rules less people will be in the church
right people don't want to go by the
rules and let's face it all of these
rules are man-made we don't know how
much was passed down from God you know
you go to church on Sunday who made that
rule don't eat meat on Friday who made
that rule then all of a sudden you can
eat meat on Fridays and you don't have
to go to church on Sunday you can go on
Saturday the man-made rules who's to say
they came I don't know yeah was it God
telling the prophets those rules
specifically or is it right people and
how far did they come down and that's
why it's good to have the rules but did
God actually send them down well that's
what a big thing with the Islamic faith
is is God told Muhammad basically he
basically told him everything to put
down into the Quran so it wasn't like he
was a writer or a great philosopher or
anything he was literally just told by
God and just the messenger yes that's
what we hear but then again there's like
the more you look into it there's like a
ton of Miracles and stuff inside of the
books that couldn't have been
scientifically proven back then like
they become true thousands of years
later and there's tons of Miracles just
like that so when you look at it it's
like what what is realistically more
likely is it a divine power telling him
that or did he just happen to get all of
this stuff right back then you know
again and we don't know I mean I believe
these messages were sent from God with
Moses with the Ten Commandments they was
you know he gave them that and it
followed through but unfortunately
through these thousands of years by the
time it trickled down it's like I don't
know if they ever did this in school the
telephone game you tell the first yeah
person you know don't go to church
Sunday and by the time it gets around to
the other to the last person yeah it has
nothing to do with church no yeah that's
some random things so it trickles down
but it's got to be your personal belief
I mean I'll never change from being a
Catholic because that's what I know I
don't care who converts to what religion
I feel everyone should have Something to
Believe In And if it makes you a better
person and you can help other people go
for it God to me is is strong God to me
is something to be feared God to me is
something someone that people are afraid
to mock yeah God to me is someone that
you have to go out of your way to prove
something to God to me has red lines
like God to me represents the Islamic
faith the Christian God to me I don't
see God I can't explain I don't see
anything there so to me it was it was
the only logical choice in the end
alhamdulillah I mean many as you're
saying this I'm sure many people are
like ecstatic and extremely happy it's a
great it's a great thing for everyone
honestly because you know just anyone
coming into Islam is you know the
prophet is better than the world and
everything in it but imagine now
somebody of major influence I mean
you're the most Googled person on the
planet I'm not sure if you're still yeah
I think Putin might have beat me as of
last week but I think it's between me
and Putin at the moment but I don't want
to lose the Putin Putin's the Big G I
don't want more enemies like it's fine
Vladimir you can have it I never thought
I'd hear you saying that statement yeah
who wouldn't beat me last year yeah I
think we're just something to most
Google but no no it's definitely
something beautiful and a lot of people
have you know you'll be surprised at how
many women as well like because
obviously the the accusations of
misogynist you know but but a lot of
women handling that especially in the
Muslim world they're absolutely happy in
fact let me tell you a story just before
I came
but she's working as a school team job
yep in London and um actually my friend
told me that she was kicked out of
school yeah because they had this
campaign against you in the schools I'm
not sure if you're aware of it yeah this
was part of the cancellation I didn't
know about this yeah so all your friends
have been watching the YouTube videos
and stuff what did they think about
Andrew Tate do they hate the guy or do
they kind of agree with him they've
actually never said really they don't
say they tell me they watch them that
they've watched you and they're happy
and they're good but they've never
really given an opinion on Andrew they
give me their opinion on you what do
they say about me no they love you oh of
course I love you they all think you're
great sometimes in like a lot of things
that they've watched and I feel the same
way they say you're great sometimes the
language gets out of hand oh yeah but
that's our generation you have to take
it back to our generation we would never
use the language so now you do I've
gotten an open mind but it I had to grow
into it no yeah I mean it didn't happen
overnight it's definitely not like some
something I'm proud of or it's just like
you said it's just different Generations
play into a different audience than 80
year olds I have an open mind but if you
spoke like that every day to me I'd
smacked you well I don't swear in front
of you you have to adjust and you have
to have an open mind to other people
some people don't with Andrew in his
views and I didn't agree with them but I
agree with I actually agree with a lot
that he says you know we just express it
differently yeah that's that's the thing
that people say about them is they agree
with what he says but they don't like
the way he says it so then when you
argue with him how do you win an
argument like that because you agree
with them you're just going after the
way he said it all right you can't well
I'm like that if people argue with me I
think I'm right so it doesn't matter
yeah so him and I would really on fit in
face to face would have a good time yeah
because we're strong-minded and I'm
always right and he's always right
yeah the the fervor behind this idea
that I'm somehow extremist is truly it's
truly clown world like I've sat as a
professional and and analyzed my content
and understood which things can be taken
out of context and which things were
said in a way perhaps they wouldn't
shouldn't have been said before I was
massively famous but we have to sit here
and understand that if you take anybody
on the planet and give them seven years
of YouTube and then they decide and they
blow up big you're gonna be able to find
30 to 45 seconds of clip across all
those years that could be taken out of
context right yeah and and and and it's
truly crazy because they sit and say oh
yeah but you know the young boys are
watching your stuff and they don't truly
understand all of it and it there's
Nuance that's missing and my argument is
very simple my argument is well one
you're taking small Clips out of context
and two there's not a single piece of
content on the internet that 14 year old
boy can't misunderstand name somebody
name someone who's producing content on
the internet that you would be 100 happy
for a 14 year old but I was just gonna
mention what he said it's interesting
how they say that but then the music
that's played on the radio is about
drugs murder and deep rapes everything
else yeah that's that's so crazy
disgusting it really is is good what
Andrew was saying I understand that's
why I don't believe anything I read
unless I saw the interview and I saw the
words come out of that person's mouth
that's the only way I believe it not
half of the things I read or see it's
just and in full context not chopped up
every two seconds I mean it's like I
hate to use this expression but fake
news fake news fake news and he's 100
right you have to say it to me out of
your mouth those were I have to see it
not read it no 100 and I agree with him
on that 100 I want to mention the names
of the artist but they're talking about
going to this person's house and killing
it and killing him in the middle of a
life crime epidemic yeah we have little
Nas twerking on having sex with the
devil in his music videos like we're
gonna sit here and talk about how
children can be impressionable young
children and I'm sitting there saying
there's no way I'm the worst person
the difference for them is as you've
mentioned on those on those fronts it
doesn't matter to them because it's like
okay they're consuming our hedonistic
products or whatever it is it doesn't
change their world view whereas what
you're saying is ideological now you're
you're challenging the status quo of the
LW of the liberal world order your
challenging second wave feministic
Notions you are challenging some liberal
Notions you are challenging ideas
commonplace ideas of of Tolerance and
George Orwell said it very well he said
that the more a society moves away from
the truth the more it hates people who
speak it absolutely and you're and
you're right and I think even the basic
things I teach because some people have
said to me Andrew all you teach about is
personal responsibility motivation
working hard getting up and doing the
right thing I said that's the absolute
those are the things they're most afraid
of if you teach people to have standards
for themselves and to be morally strong
people and to know right from wrong then
they can't brainwash you so that's what
they're most afraid of they're most
afraid of young men waking up and going
no I don't believe that you have to
believe it no I don't believe it I don't
want to and I want to go do this I want
to go to the gym and be strong or I want
to believe X or I want to be a moral
person they genuinely have a problem
with Baseline morality yes understand
one who is like the Andrew Tate figure
when you were growing up was there a guy
like that preaching a lot of the same
stuff about self-discipline no nothing
nothing I mean we had I think it was
Saturday night Bishop Sheen he was a
bishop with the Catholic church and St
Patrick's Cathedral gave a talk a speech
whatever you want to call it every
Saturday night I guess and it was about
morals and doing right and doing bad in
a different way he spoke differently and
but basically when you go back it's the
same thing that Andrew's saying that
there's different words different times
you know it's the same thing you could
pick up a newspaper from 1945 and pick
up a newspaper today the stories are the
same they're just written differently
different people and people have become
too many people are allowed to say too
many things yeah that's a good way to
put it yeah yeah back back in the day if
there was a dummy and they wanted to
spill their thoughts they went to the
barbershop and that's where that's where
it went out and died go to the bar
now everybody has a platform everybody
is right they think they're right and
wrong but your basic morals go back to
them and your basic morals will make you
do the right thing could you see why the
people who control the world would want
to consultate because he has influence
afraid they're afraid that he's saying
too much the truth as the other
gentleman said The more you stay away
from the truth the harder it is to
believe it and it's true you turn your
head and then when somebody actually
does speak the truth nah he's full of
it's no it's not real and you have to
pay attention do you think we live in
like the dumbest generation that's ever
thought they're the smartest I don't
know if we're the dumbest I think we're
the one the generation with the least
common sense some people recognize when
I convert to Islam that there was a time
I was an atheist there was a time when I
was atheistic and the reason I am now so
absolutely certain that God is real is
because I've seen evil I've seen shaytan
I've seen it when you see enough evil
you realize that there must be an equal
and opposite force and there are people
out there in the world today doing the
work of the devil genuine demons who are
trying to destroy the Baseline morality
that's inside of all of us we're all
born with some kind of morality and
they're trying to destroy it and that's
exactly the Islamic understanding that
we believe that you're born with
something called which is the initial
goodness you're you're born with an
innate belief receptivity to believe in
one God and then that is corrupted in
fact there's a prophet Hadith of the
Prophet where he says
[Music]
every born child is born upon this
initial goodness
and then his father and mother or his
parents they socialize him into you know
Christianity Judaism and magism so the
idea is that everyone is born with this
initial uh goodness and this initial
will or want to believe in God one God
and then as you mentioned I mean it's
what you're mentioning here is really is
profound because you're you're
mentioning a central Doctrine in Islam
but but it's and and and this is why
perhaps I found God the way I did
because I understood all these things
first and then I saw the Quran and
confirmed so many things for me you know
like even the conversations I've been
having so far so many things have been
confirmed and it's amazing the knowledge
that's inside of it which is so
applicable today yeah for for an old
book right you know it's supposed to be
old but it seems so so Timeless but it's
truly amazing but you're you're totally
right and and the Baseline morality I
don't think most people understand that
when they're doing this under the guise
of Tolerance when they're saying be so
tolerant that you no longer believe in
right from wrong they're not doing that
to make Society a better place they're
doing that to empty your brain so that
you have no resistance to the slave mind
programming they want to get you to a
point where if they tell you the sky is
green yeah you look at with your own
eyes it's it's interesting I've really
been ignorant I don't remember the other
gentleman's name but when he said we're
all born with good we're all born good
and the Catholic religion Catholicism
original sin original sin we are not
born perfect and that's why we we have a
baptism to rid us of that original sin
and then again what he said your parents
at that point instill in you the
moralities The Good the Bad and then
hopefully we're never going to be
perfect nobody's ever perfect but if you
get rid of that sin original sin you
know and you have the right person
teaching you you can I don't care what
religion you're in if you're taught
right from the beginning and your
parents give you a little smack now and
then I think it'll work out my husband
and your grandpa used to say when
somebody did these stupid things or said
these stupid things that hates talking
about Grandpa always said they never got
it beaten they never gotta beaten
therefore that was his words he says
that his father never smacked the crap
out of him not to kill him but
teach him a lesson and get that evil out
of you you have to again back to fear
you have to have fear what was it like
when um Muhammad Ali converted to Islam
oh my God thinking about it I mean he
was such a you know a good fighter and I
mean well back at the time there was a
lot of talk for not going to war in
Vietnam because the religion wouldn't
let him go to law so he converted so
there was a lot of controversy oh people
were saying like he converted just so he
didn't have to go to war right oh I
didn't even know that I mean I remember
you know hearing that I mean if you
convert it because that's what he really
believed and wanted good for him all the
more power to him it's like I'm sure he
had the political connections to not go
to war anyways he's Muhammad Ali right
it's like yeah but he was more famous
after he became Muhammad Ali he was a
good fighter and Faith but once all that
controversy you know you do something
wrong you become famous people don't
like you I'm sure Tate is more popular
now that he got thrown out of yeah I
know exactly thrown out and fired their
last bullet imagine shooting a man with
your last bullet and he stands there
unfazed but the real followers are still
going to follow him you're not gonna
knock them down and he shouldn't be
knocked down he's has a right to say
what he wants when you were a kid and
there was some like the media told you
someone's bad would the whole world like
so nowadays if someone gets canceled or
something and then somebody gives them a
platform so like Andrew Tate's canceled
if someone has them on his podcast
people will go after that person and be
like I can't believe you give this
person a platform and allow them to
speak like was that a thing back sure it
was the only thing that now with all of
the mediums that we have he can go on
another medium when I was young there
were no other mediums there was radio
and television so when somebody got
black bold they that's what they called
it back then black bold black bald mend
you didn't get a movie you didn't go on
television or radio they were the only
three mediums there were and you were
Blackboard black bald I've never heard
that yeah we gotta bring that back very
old expression that's so it's 82 years
old so you know it when it's so funny
though how it's like the same thing it's
the same concept and it's just
and then they do everything with the
Trojan Horse now so it's the same stuff
they're doing but they just do it in a
different way that gets the same result
but no the sky is green that's what they
want so that you have to have nothing in
your brain that can prevent that if you
have God if you have no I believe this
is right and wrong if you have personal
responsibility if you have
self-accountability if you're a person
who sticks up for what he believes all
that's bad to them they want all of that
gone so they could tell you the sky is
green and and I don't want to say too
much because I don't want the stream to
end but they're going to tell you
something much worse than the sky is
green they're going to tell you
something else and and if they're trying
to program us all into slaves I remember
when I was in my undergraduate days and
I was reading a particular book by this
guy called Jeremy Bentham who became
like you know the spiritual forefather
of Jose Mill who is the father of like
social liberalism of today and I
remember reading this because it was so
powerful because it linked to something
I read in the Quran he said that you
know you have two gods he said you have
the god of pain and you have the God of
Pleasure and I thought this is so
interesting the Quran States you know
have you seen the one who takes his own
desires as a God and because now there
is no transcendental force that we can
look up and as you say venerate now
we're forced to be slaves to the system
we're to our own desires or I mean the
Quran has another verse which I think is
so powerful and it connects very well
with what you're saying
that God has struck a parable of a man
that he's got many different slave
owners
and another kind of man who's only got
one slave owner he's God is basically
telling us in the Quran that you've got
one example of one individual who's got
multiple slave owners and another one
with just one he says are they the same
so here the idea is
as Rousseau said that his liberal
philosophy said that man is Born Free
but everywhere in Chains
this is the order because if you don't
have that God to to worship then you're
going to end up having to worship to
everything else and the whole part of
the shahada which you took which is
the the true meaning of that is that
there is no God worthy of worship except
for one God which means that yours your
desires or the system or these people
that want to control us they are the
problem is they're not worthy of worship
the only one worthy of our subordination
and submission is the creator of the
heavens and the Earth there's no one
else I agree and it's it's it's I
completely agree and I've agreed with
this for the longest time you know I've
never been to like a music concert and
people ask me why and I said I just look
at it and I feel embarrassed I look at
someone up on a stage dancing around and
I look at hundreds of thousands of
peasants in the crowd just yeah yeah
yeah I'm like it's embarrass I feel
cringe it's like secondhand
embarrassment when I see these festivals
and everyone's losing their mind or
these music concerts I genuinely feel
embarrassed for the people who go
because to me that is a form of worship
like yeah you can listen to the music at
home for free like you don't have to
wait in that line and stand out in the
cold like I don't know entertainers they
may be the worst people in the world but
talented people I am in such awe of
people with talent I love listening to
them I don't act like an idiot like you
know some of these people do but no I I
think it's nice to go see people and if
it means waiting online although I don't
really wait online I I don't like that
but people do it and uh no that's
Entertainment that's okay there's
nothing wrong with that yeah no I I
definitely see exactly what he's saying
with festivals and stuff and people are
just like crammed together and they're
just like it's like well they idolize
people they idolize this Entertainer and
that's the thing these people that don't
have a god they idolize these
entertainers and then he's saying like
it's almost like a form of worship where
you're going here and you're like
idolizing this person who creates music
and you're standing there and everyone's
like I can separate them when I used to
go see Frank Sinatra or Shirley dassey I
loved loved them but I feel like that's
different from heaven but I could
separate my personal religion God from
those people I don't idolize them in the
same way yep I feel like that's
different because back then you'd go and
you'd sit down in a seat and you just
enjoy the music and it's it's just
completely different than nowadays oh
today I mean you have 50 000 people
clammed into an arena I wouldn't go I
I've been to a couple but I will not I
would never do that again I'm past that
I'm through with that yeah perhaps it
was a bit extreme but I've always known
that they're trying to give us false
Idols to some degree and when I speak to
atheists atheists think oh I don't
believe in God but they they've signed
up so hard to the liberal woke agenda
they're as religious as anybody but
they're just believing in the wrong
things they're believing in degeneracy
and they're believing in the work of the
devil so that's a crazy statement right
there but it's the truth it is a crazy
statement and that's if that's what the
religion if it's called a religion I
don't know atheism I mean if that's what
they believe in that's fine but give
them their own Island and their own yeah
get them out of here get them away from
me humans always need something to
believe in and it's a great thing you
said about your own desires it's like
one one guy I was talking to since my
conversion says it's interesting that
somebody with everything all the Western
World yeah I think everything somebody
could want is that has now converted and
I said yeah because even before my
conversion I understood that Hedonism is
a black hole and you can never fill it
you're never going to be able to have
enough girls to be happy with girls
you're never going to be able to have
enough money to be happy with money you
know be able to you know drink enough to
be happy with drinking like it's a black
hole and you can pour endless things
down it but you'll never fill it up and
you need to have some degree of
self-restraint and I've always been a
very disciplined person I've never made
mistakes but certainly yeah the higher
power is is going to give you more
satisfaction in your heart than endless
endless Insanity what do you think of
that well you can't say even if it makes
mistakes that's egotistical it's a big
ego like we all make mistakes it could
be minor nobody is perfect and we learn
from those mistakes I feel like he
because obviously he doesn't mean he
hasn't made a mistake like yeah he's
like forgotten his phone somewhere or
something like like everyone has made
mistakes but I think he means like he
goes into every decision with utmost
confidence well he researches everything
I don't think he's just woke up
yesterday and says I'm changing my
religion there had to be problems with
his religion over years over years I
mean I see my religion Catholicism and
it's far far from perfect a lot of times
I just don't agree with it but I just go
back to my Basics and if you go back to
your Basics you could stay with whatever
you are but if you want to change as
Andrew was doing nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with it as long as he's
changing for good reasons not just
because well I don't want to be
Christian today they're no good they're
not bad you have to have a good reason
to change it seems like he's been
pointing out some pretty good reasons
yeah and I mean I understand I
understand his like what he says about
the Catholic church and stuff like that
there's a lot going on with the Catholic
church but for me I still would never
change
um has your perspective about Islam and
stuff changed a lot after watching a lot
of the videos because personally I know
I've had a very American point of view
about it like I didn't know what the
Quran was a few months ago every time
time I've thought about Islam it was
just the bad things that you see on the
media I never realized Jesus was in the
Quran or a part of it like I genuinely
just saw it as like this random language
completely random religion I know
nothing about it the you know women are
can't do anything like that's because
that's just what shoved down your throat
all the time about it you know what
America is we're a very spoiled society
and we have our religions and of course
Muslims right now Muslims are getting a
bad rap on everything yeah but it's not
the Muslims it's the politicians it's
the politicians in America in Europe in
Muslim countries they're good people I
have no qualms about meeting and talking
with Muslims or any religion or
nationality as long as you're good
people it's okay all right guys thank
you so much for watching if you're
interested in learning how to make money
online and get some free social media
chips tips check out my Discord we've
already had a bunch of people doing
really well so far so you can start too
no reason you can't also make sure to
follow me on Instagram at sunnyfaz and
drop in the comments if you want more
videos with the based Grandma yeah I'm
here
she's got the she can she can come out
whenever we're here in the Florida
Sunshine oh yeah but all right guys
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you later
[Music]
[Music]